just skip the turkey
here now with reaction is columnist
monica crowley fox news contributor
laura trump and fox news contributor
miranda divine ladies thank you so much
for being here
monica are they that
out of touch that they don't understand
that when people see their lives
changing especially how far their money
goes it actually does matter do they
think they can deflect their way out of
this for real
well you know pete they have desperately
tried to define inflation and also try
to minimize it we've heard from the
president the vice president jen saki
we've heard from the chair of the
federal reserve the treasury secretary
janet yellen all for months calling
inflation transitory don't worry so much
it's going to be temporary well the fed
just today put out a statement saying
inflation might not be all that
transitory and we stand ready perhaps
sooner rather than later to actually
deal with it look they don't really care
that americans are being squeezed by
higher prices because it's all being
done pete in the name of the fundamental
transformation of the nation so they
have a broader ideological agenda here
to remake the the economy re-engineer
the relationship between the government
the individual and the economy so if
they have to break a few eggs if
americans have to
forego their turkey and have a hot dog
tomorrow instead well for them it's
actually worth it because their agenda
is much more long-range and long-term
and uh it doesn't seem to be bothering
joe biden who is sitting now in a
billionaire's compound on nantes yes i
mean let them eat tofu turkey and enjoy
it uh laura but that is it seems to be
what the left always does right they
they tell us to lower expectations get
used to dealing with less i mean it's
we're doing bigger better thing more
important things passing trillion dollar
bills and and fighting the climate i
mean how dare you quibble over you know
a couple of dollars
yeah well it would be uh interesting if
it just was the turkey i mean i you
heard jen sake there say well it's the
turkey it's about a dollar more for 20
pounds it's actually not it's a lot more
than that but it's everything pete
everything costs more now so it's not
just the turkey and to piggyback off of
uh something that monica just said there
she was spot on they have told us from
the beginning that they want to
fundamentally transform america well how
do you do that you have to change
america from the inside out you have to
take away our tradition so it might seem
a little funny and a little ridiculous
oh don't have a turkey then people won't
come over we're last year remember they
didn't even want us to get together so i
guess we're lucky they're letting us
have thanksgiving here you should think
but at really the core of this
they want to divide americans up they
don't want us to have any common ground
they don't want us to have any shared
traditions like thanksgiving a lot of
places last month actually did away with
halloween because they wanted to be
inclusive of the people that didn't
celebrate halloween we know that's a
very very small group of people
halloween is a great occasion for the
kids to get candy and dress up but it
all goes to fundamentally transforming
this country and the way you do that is
you make sure that we have no
commonality whatsoever no traditions as
americans whatsoever you start chipping
away at that and they don't care that
thanksgiving costs a lot more whether
you're driving to somebody's house this
year paying for all that food on the
table they don't care joe biden is
certainly very happy right now where he
is for thanksgiving yeah no i mean i do
take issue with the fact that halloween
trick-or-treating now happens during the
day
uh you know back in the day it happened
at night it was supposed to be spooky
you know a little risky now it's all
during the day but i digress miranda i i
will say when it comes to the media
when you see the clip skip the turkey
the inflation's not all that big of a
deal make sure you have coveted tests
for your attendees uh at your
thanksgiving they seem to go to no end
to want to cover up and we can do the
contrast of what was done to laura's
father but how far can they go to
attempt to make things that are glaring
and real right in front of our face seem
like they're not a big deal
you're so right honestly it is like a
giant gaslighting operation and it comes
from the media and it comes from the
white house and it comes from joe biden
himself and it's not working
you just look at the polls you see that
americans are
worried about the economy they're
worried about inflation
they're worried about their hip pocket
they're worried about gas prices they're
worried about the direction that the
country is going in and they blame joe
biden they say
you know he pretended that he was going
to heal the divisions in the country
that was why a lot of people voted for
him and he hasn't done it you just look
at the polls and they're going down the
tubes really fast and yet joe biden
doesn't seem to care i mean the optics
are pretty bad of his going off for five
days for a holiday
in one of the most exclusive resort
islands in the world
at the 30 million dollar compound of a
billionaire
but he doesn't care i mean this is a
time when the economy is reeling from
what a really self-inflicted crises
he's allowed to go on a holiday but he
just uh this is who he is i mean he's
always been
really a man who he and his family live
a life of luxury and immense privilege
unimaginable to most americans and uh i
think that they're starting to realize
this and and if if the democrats think
that they're going to run
in 2022 just uh on trump derangement
syndrome they're going to get a pretty
sad shock because donald trump in polls
already is beating joe biden by as much
as 10 points
yeah it's amazing i mean when you build
your entire career and your entire
family's wealth on government service
you create that barrier buffer of
actually interacting with real people
and how it impacts their lives monica
laura and miranda happy thanksgiving to
all three of you thank you so much for
being with us